[Music]
dude there was a point there was a point
where i really was like this is my life
now i just bloody shits every day
oh damn
that's something i don't have blood it's
just really good scratch my ass all
right three two one actions here we go
anybody know who this guy is
it's a soccer player
some people might call him a football
player but yes i have never seen him
before am i am i stupid i think he's a
goalie because you're wearing gloves
we're just not european am i unaware
like what am i am i like let me let me
send you a culture let me show you a
second video
of the same guy
oh this is a bad disclaimer oh is this
something breaking bro
is he going to kick somebody in the
balls
so what
suck him up
bro he did he kick her cat bruh wait was
that a real cat real cat no is he still
kicking cats
oh my god did he just slam it
she's like you threw a shoe at it
and then there's like one more clip
where he's uh
nah bro that's not cool you can't be
doing that
there should be one more clip where i
think a kid is
right here
oh my god what the [__] is the objective
there
that should look like a little leopard
wow yeah it's a bengal i have bengals oh
yo that's crazy that's cool so how'd
this make you feel like wildcats
[__] dude yeah uh no they're not
uh well i don't i'm pretty sure these
are bengals because they don't look like
savannahs or larger cats or anything
like that um holy [__] i don't like that
your cats look like designer cats like
it's wild cats they are kind of wild
they're they're very close to their uh
asian leopard cat uh descendants yeah
that should rush me the wrong way yeah i
don't like that [__] but like if i were
to try to think for them do they live in
a country where they like don't value
animals the same yeah is that like
commonplace
uh no i think regardless i think it's
not right i don't know any country that
yeah i don't know goalie kicks a [__]
member cat you're a soccer player now
you can't be kicking cats so this guy is
uh he's on he's a west ham defender his
name is kurt
zouma
and he's reportedly said to be
prosecuted under the animal welfare act
after being filmed kickings is this in
the uk
um
west ham i think so yeah because the
reason why i was even thinking that i'm
like whoever is filming it obviously
thinks it's okay um yeah so i'm liking
the same thing through that lens is it
okay wherever they're from i guess but
it rubs me the wrong way for sure you
know that's true because there's places
where they have a different relationship
with like animals they don't even know
the idea of what is animal abuse
do you think that the second that you're
into you're like a part of like an
international
like literally this is a football club
that's like international right the
second you go into that you're also
now in the international community
therefore maybe yeah there's no excuse
for [__] like i i think like if you're
like a high level soccer player like
it's like being in an nba right like
we're not talking about a guy that's
like
you know you know in some third world
country that's like like playing soccer
barefoot and like he might be this is on
his social media
well this uh i'm not exactly sure where
so the guy who filmed it was a guy named
joanne zouma which i guess is his
brother because they have the same last
name um
rspca spokesperson said following a full
and thorough investigation we have
started the process of bringing a
prosecution against kurt zoluma and
joanne zoluma under the animal welfare
act the two cats continue to be careful
cared for by the rspca and we will be in
a position to release more information
once the court date is confirmed the
footage of this
uh was circulating on social media last
month around february 7th
and uh that was a public post yeah dude
what the [__] are you thinking
that's [__] crazy the lack of common
sense with this yeah bro why would you
even have an animal if you're gonna beat
it that's that was his cat i would
assume so yeah i mean i think the best
thing is we should have [__] like a like
a football player the real football in
america right
you know how many [__] dudes
we'll have we'll have uh we'll have a uh
[__] um this guy be the ball for our
super bowl
like his
balls with those legs open and they come
and [__] kick him in the nuts
world-renowned soccer player who [__]
kicks cat will now get kicked in the
ball
and then dude this dude runs up
boom or we could get a horse
and then paint them the colors of a cat
and then place it with crackers and have
a [__] bun
paint the horse a cat like somebody else
isn't going to have an issue with us
[Laughter]
poetic animal justice
[Music]
well i thought you were going to paint
him into a cat oh
i like that
and then paint the horse a human
hit the horse the shocker oh
creative thinking together teamwork kind
of idiots publicly post something like
that that's just like yeah pretty
[__] dumb right i just don't like the
animal abuse stuff like that bro cause
it's like oh my god
yeah of course of course obviously
but as far as like because certain
people like what bart says right like
certain people treat animals a certain
way just like culturally like some
people like you ever been to someone's
house that you don't really like you're
hanging out with a friend and then the
way they treat their dog
or their animal you're just like
ah that makes me feel some type of way
you know i've never been in someone's
house like that really i've been in some
people's houses where i'm like everyone
i go to they're pretty good with that
i'm like hey bro like you shouldn't be
hitting your dog like that like what are
you doing
or like they the way they they keep
their dog outside and they barely take
care of them like [__] like that
like that you see stuff like that you're
just like oh man but i feel like for
certain people they have this like
a sense of
oh i should be able to do this because
i'm a human being and
you know and i feel like i just it makes
me feel some type of way when i see that
stuff dude well like what's the scope of
the type of [__] these guys do normally
if they thought that wouldn't be bad
yeah that's what's scary to me i'm like
that must if that's nothing in their
like realm of [__] to do to me to me the
thing that gets me
uh really like well is
they seem like they're having fun yeah
they're laughing too much like even the
kids doing it yeah like it's just
there's like this this like let's record
multiple instances it's like laugh while
it's happening like gamify it you know
what i mean yeah and i think that's
different than like um
not trying to justify it but like i
don't know um
a moment where you're
i can't even say it like a pet does
something wrong with the [__] does a pet
know about right and wrong you know what
i'm saying but like
it's not yeah it's not like a moment
we're like oh you [__] this up
therefore i am you know what i mean
that's their source of entertainment it
looks like a joke it looks like a fun
thing it's not like that that pet shop
person when they were taking care of
like 50 dogs and she got stressed and
tossed one
i did not see that no yeah i mean that
was like the stress of her job getting
to her and she was like [__] the dogs
weren't a listener so she just
threw one and launched it but like this
is purely like yeah this is like
laughing yeah yeah
i think we should dress them up into a
cat
and spray
tiger [__] juice on them and throw them
in a tiger cage with
40 tigers and see what happens
i love the access to tiger [__] juice
and the access to horny tigers
that's kind of high budget
that's [__] good though or if europe
wants to get a hold of them then what
we'll do is we'll paint them into a
soccer ball and for every
you know soccer game
we'll kick them into the goal
what's worse this or the the um that
athlete who had the dog fighting ring
that was a dog isn't that michael vick
yeah what i think that's worse yeah
that's that's for sure those are the
dogs fighting to the death right like
they've got dogs
gamifying betting on it yeah it's the
whole [__] thing cheering that it
gets hurt that's [__] up yeah because
this is one that's they technically have
a family member that they just treat
like [__] i guess right
and this guy's got this guy's got 1.9
million followers on ig he's 27 years
old he said i want to apologize for my
actions there are no excuses for my
behavior which i sincerely regret i also
want to say how deeply actually i don't
even want to read this guy's apology
point is you [__] up but it's cool
that he he actually had to apologize i
hope he means it got some weird [__]
like roundabout
did he lose his
position yeah job or anything like that
i think they're undergoing the
prosecution it's very recent this later
happened like a month ago i don't know
if the club had suspended him uh
it says the spokesperson for the club
said west ham united unreservedly
condemns the actions of our player kurt
zouma in the video that has circulated
we have spoken to to kurt and we'll be
dealing with the matter internally but
we would like to make it clear that we
in no way condone cruelty towards
animals damn
that's so [__] up dude
i mean how does the club's reputation
survive that
like everyone's just gonna [__] hate
them all right no i think the club's
reputation is easy as long as they snip
the bad egg you know what i mean right
that's what i mean like if they leave
him on the team then that's the bad move
like they kind of have to kick him out
right unless he's like the best player
that's ever come to that club in like 40
yeah he's like oh man no one could kick
a cat like that guy oh
you can kick a ball you can kick a cat
she's like
but i think they'll probably like just
find them and just slap them on the
wrist suspend them and that's whack man
i think we could create we should create
a whole new game for this guy like every
soccer game
we're gonna have this dude with a cat
uniform right with cat ears and
everything right
the two of the teams come up and the
game will be he has to run around the
field and try to not get kicked you have
all these soccer players chase this
[__] and kick the [__] out of
him you see but then even then though
here's the crazy part because even in
that game
the people that are trying to kick him
are the same size as him yeah think
about like the size of like a cat like
you gotta have the person kicking you'd
be like [__] 14 x your size he has to
pull up
like on all fours and he has to say now
he's gotta do this yeah he has to play
like a cat
he's gotta drink a milk out of a sausage
he's got to say meow he's got to say
meow and he has to crawl
and then we're going to replace all the
europeans with new zealand polynesians
that have steel toe boots steel toe
boots that have been practiced kicking
because this guy's he plays soccer so
he's got a trained foot as well okay
that's true yeah what we'll do is get a
bunch of coaching practitioners which
are taekwondo taekwondo guys
and uh they'll do a number on him we'll
do those little flutter kicks to the
side but don't forget he's gotta have
tiger [__] juice on him yeah yeah the
whole time and then after that we
release the tigers on him isn't it funny
that a guy can get a video of him
kicking a cat and just [__] everyone
hates him but the dude who financed 911
has someone fighting for his [__]
rights
don't [__] with cats man don't [__] with
cats dude
[Music]
do